[Music]
Poland's military is flexing its Arsenal
in the largest parade in decades this
Army days to Mark 103 years since
winning the Battle of Warsaw against the
Soviets and it's a significant display
of how billions have been spent on new
equipment since 2014 when Russia annexed
Crimea
we are modernizing our Armed Forces this
year we will allocate over four percent
of GDP on defense we live in dangerous
times again a full-scale war is taking
place beyond our eastern border a war
that still has no end in sight
but not everyone is convinced the
opposition says the government is
politicizing the military
there are those who criticize this
ambitious program there are those who
loudly remind us that we are getting
into debt to buy Modern equipment when I
hear these voices I always say we cannot
afford to be idle today
even before the war in Ukraine Poland
began bolstering its military the close
ties between Russia and neighboring
Belarus have been a catalyst to purchase
more Conventional Weapons
we thought we lived in times of small
mobile armies but it turns out that we
live in an era of artillery and tank
battles Poland is a much richer country
compared to 10 20 years ago however it's
still not a rich country in terms of
military Investments the cost of buying
weapons is only one-third of the
operating costs over the entire period
of maintaining of the equipment
much of the further expansion of Polish
Army will depend on how the war in
Ukraine progresses and until there's
fear of it spilling into Poland is
likely to be support for public
investment in defense
right now there is no single person who
wouldn't purity especially if you have a
family
our army is now strong I personally feel
safe and if needed I would take up arms
and go
more than 100 years since the war with
the former Soviet Union a shadow of War
still looms under Poland Belarus border
and that is why the government continues
to tell its people that it needs a
strong powerful Army Warsaw
sir